yeah the stuff is definitely there he's
got some of the best secondary stuff in
the league and he's been going out there
and doing a very good job and it's hard
to believe that he is a guy who hasn't
pitched above a ball and here he is in
the big leagues putting up great numbers
and getting that all-star comment put
around him and a lot of the reason is
because of the innings pitched and that
low era at 2.83
paul thorne
lost him and back-to-back walks
from luis garcia conversation with cb
going you got to help my boy out man
there you go the veteran pitching coach
saying my guy is out here competing i
need you to compete too and figure out
where that strike zone is and there's
didn't want to have it from cb buckner
and the orioles threatening in the first
inning with anthony santander
swing and a miss comes back to get
anthony santander big strikeout there
one away in the first first and second
here's ryan mount castle
breaking ball fair ball into the left
field corner that'll get mullins is in
mount castle around third he gets the
green light here comes trey and the
orioles have a two nothing lead one out
two on for michael franco at a big night
yesterday another pitch to franco's
sixth of the at-bat swinging up base hit
rocketed to right of center field straw
is over to cut it off mount castle will
score easily standing up michael franco
continues to assault houston pitching
got him back-to-back change-ups to end
the inning yeah matt harvey uh will try
to break this uh long losing streak
both three and nine high era and more
innings obviously
more hits than innings pitched doesn't
really walk a lot of guys doesn't give
up that many home runs
oh and he waves at that one well there's
your slider
2-2 swing and a foul tip into the mid of
severino strike three
little tapper
franco cuts across and gets him
and a chopper towards altube two big
hops for jose
and aureus is retired for the first down
in the second inning
curve ball and that's hitting the air
out to right center coming in straw
racing and now he's called off by tucker
ground ball towards third that's going
to be a fair ball garcia the throw
nicely done in time to get mancini
strong arm by rebel garcia
breaking ball right back and into the
glove
yeah it's nice to have it to your glove
side not hit real hard
bounce to short
maria's throws across two down 1-0
swinging a ground ball to the right side
and the ship to rius in front of labor
fields and throws out tucker
that one slicing down the left field
line michael brantley has a play on it
as he eases up before he gets near the
line payoff in route
swing and a miss mount castle strikes
out
swinging a miss luis garcia
punches out the final two mount castle
and stewart a one two three third that's
now eight in a row sent down by luis
with what he wanted to do 2-2 garcia
swing and a miss he goes after a
breaking ball from matt harvey that's
his third strikeout
[Applause]
right center
no problem for santa and dare two down
bounce to the right side
mancini takes it himself
and matt harvey set the first nine down
in order
he has since turned things around
although michael franco bidding for a
hit but miles straw will
watch that one into his glove as it
holds up
oh
yeah beautifully done
and he delivers
swing a fly ball out to center field
well hit straw going back at the track
at the wall he makes the catch
first and second for the astros on back
to back phase hit lord on hit a soft
line drive back to the pitcher harvey
his first time up
into center field that's going to fall
for a hit brantley will be waved around
here comes cedric mullen's throw it will
be not in time and wide aggressive send
by omar lopez and the astros score a run
they're now down by the score of four to
one correa grounded out his first time
up he has a career home run against this
right-hander 3-2
correa swings and he drives the ball
into right field playing back anthony
santander makes the catch tagging up
from second heading in for third julie
guriel the throw is not in time
now it's up to kyle tucker to keep this
frame going here for the astros
and the pitch to tucker is grounded
through the whole left side a base hit
scoring is guriel
and it's now a two run ball game four to
two orioles as tucker goes the other way
and beats the shift astros have the
tying runs aboard for michael brantley
strike three threw it by him at 98 two
down
popped up right side mancini there makes
the catch and what a job by tanner scott
comes in and gets two big outs
one two to alvarez oh that's a strike
got him looking
0-2 right down the middle 99
tanner scott ready 2-2 on the way
and he threw it by him at 97. so tanner
scott strikes out the side making his
big league debut
is a 27 year old from anaheim california
and that's ryan hartman
swaying at a foul tip ryan hartman
strikes out ryan mount castle
bounce mancini there's one put the tag
on him and he's out at second
in hard one hopper trey backhands it
he'll take it himself but austin hayes
will bat the first time tonight hayes
came into the game defensively in the
seventh inning 2-2 pitch
hit hard down the left field line that's
a fair ball home run
second of the series for
austin hayes
a solo shot absolutely lasered down the
left field line it is
five to two orioles in the eighth astros
down to their final out
popped up they should do it let's see
mckenna coming hard
he gets there nice play
yeah
austin hayes happy but
franco winning hard i think that's uh
they have injured his ankle he said help
me up made to beat
the labor
so just a little damper after you know
just a great great sweep of the astros
right you have an injury here but uh boy
the orioles played some baseball